que de pression et que d'efforts
déployés pour ces joutes politiques que
représentent les débats des chefs en
campagne électorale
cette campagne se suivent d'inusité que
les chefs doivent se prêter à l'exercice
quatre fois en deux semaines imaginé
après les débats du global mer jeudi ce
sera le débat radio canada à la presse
en français jeudi prochain puis suivront
deux autres débats sur les affaires
étrangères et à tva
la semaine suivante sauf diraient
certains qui de mieux placé pour en
discuter
que nos stratèges je les rejoins vous
allez voir ils sont vraiment aux quatre
routes du pays cette semaine
robert asselin conseiller de justin
trudeau vous êtes à halifax
catherine loubier conseillère de stephen
harper pour le québec vous êtes à
windsor
karl bélanger conseiller principal de
thomas mulcair vous êtes à saint jean
terre neuve et cette semaine comme on
parle des baquets les débats français
aussi bien on a invité dominique
vallières directeur des relations de
presse du bloc québécois vous êtes à
québec donc bon dimanche à vous quatre
commencé avec vous monsieur vallières
vous êtes le nouveau venu pour expliquer
monsieur madame tout le monde c'est quoi
la chose la plus importante qu'on
prépare un dea baup un chef pour un
débat des chefs
ben en fait c'est le contenu puis
monsieur duceppe le 10 puis on le voit
bien dans la préparation ce qui est la
meilleure préparation pour le débat
c'est la campagne elle-même support au
fil des rencontres qui vaut faire noté
des noms des témoignages des
circonscriptions puis garder ça puis
amener ça avec lui dans les différentes
séances de préparation pour être en
mesure de donner une couleur c'est un
petit peu plus un peu plus locales ou
régionales
ou indifférentes aux différents clips
qui va sortir vos différentes lignes qui
va sortir 4 et nous avait un chef qui a
une grande expérience de ces débats là
le ton est pas toujours le même que des
objectifs précis qui dépendent des
campagnes électorales que vous vous que
vous vous fixez avec lui quand vous le
préparez
oui absolument il ya les objectifs
précis de la campagne qui sont qui sont
très importants mais aussi il peut avoir
des enjeux qui surviennent dans les
jours avant le débat alors il faut bien
bien ajuster le temps et être certains
de passer nos messages et il faut voir
quel ton on adopte ce que c'est un ton
calme plus ferme ou même une touche
d'humour tout dépendante de la
personnalité des des autres leaders et
c'est justement dans la pratique de tout
ça con qu'on prépare le chef à faire
face aux différentes personnalités et ce
qu'on doit anticiper des autres leaders
justement parlant de personnalités
robert car vous avez préparé plusieurs
chiffres dans vos carrières à des débats
des chefs
ce à quoi ça sert cet exercice est est
ce que si encore utiliser cette idée de
faire un faux studio de demander à
déconseiller à des députés de jouer les
adversaires donc vraiment faire un jeu
de rôle car je commence avec vous
absolument c'est une façon pour
s'entraîner c'est un peu comme un match
de boxe on a des partenaires
d'entraînement avec lesquels on simule
le match alors on simule le débat en
temps de mettre le chef dans le bain de
ce qui va arriver lors de la vraie
situation
donc on a des gens qui personnifie les
différents chefs et qui tente de trouver
les lignes d'attaqué pour aider les
chefs à bien répondre à cette attaque la
halle et prévoit par exemple moi j'ai
pendant quelques années
jouer gilles duceppe j'ai presque autant
d'expériences qui agissait pas préparé
des bottes en tant que 17
mais ça aide beaucoup les chefs à voir
venir les coups et surtout à
contre-attaqué question que tout le
monde se pose et qu'on joue gilles
duceppe avec son chef néo démocrate
on se met complètement dans l'at elle
d'être un blocus comment ça fonctionne
c'est quoi l'idée mais on essaie de
faire ça parce que il faut rendre
la simulation la plus véridique possible
alors évidemment on se tient au courant
là des différents programmes des lignes
sont utilisant point presse et on tente
aussi de voir venir
quels seront les stratégies qui seront
les lits les angles d'attaqué pour bien
préparer le chef à toute éventualité
évidemment on peut pas tout faire on
peut tout deviné mais ça ça permet aux
jeunes d'être sur ses gardes de
s'entraîner et d'avoir des belles des
belles lignes de contre attaque lorsque
le besoin se fait sentir
robert toujours pertes pertinence et
jeux de rôles creuse pour un chef moins
expérimentés qu'un chef plus
expérimentés ou si universelle non pour
moi la simulation la principale fonction
c'est vraiment la forme le fond les
chefs enlèvement par là qu'ils sont dans
la campagne connaissent leurs messages
et savent ce qu'ils veulent communiquer
ce qui est vraiment important pour eux
c'est comprendre
en bon français le flot du débat comment
la question va venir ça va être quoi la
répartie vous savez chaque débat est
différent les règles sont jamais les
mêmes
alors c'est ça qui est important dans
une simulation c'est que le chef
comprennent bon et j'ai trente secondes
pour répondre à ça après ça va être leur
chef lors il peut revenir à moi alors
c'est vraiment là où c'est important de
faire les simulations mais moi je vous
dirais les débats en bout de ligne
synthes d'authenticité on peut préparer
un chef de différentes façons on peut
lui donner des lignes d'avant ce si à la
fin du débat les gens semble que le chef
est vraiment c'est pas clair son message
ça venait pas vraiment d'où il y avait
là de dire des lignes qu'on lui a donné
ça fonctionne balle à la préparation
d'un chef berry vraiment d'un individu à
l'autre mais en bout de ligne faut que
le chef soit à l'aise tout cas l'air
d'être authentique il faut qui livre son
message le plus simplement possible
robert un peu raison et on peut préparer
un chef
on peut être sous préparé mais un danger
aussi quand on est sûr préparé et alors
là on peut sonner tout à fait script et
pour les gens ça sonne pas authentique
effectivement
les lignes qui tue tout le monde y va de
notre jeune soeur c'est comme devenu
mythique maintenant tous les débats on
espère qu'il va en avoir eu dominique
seux commencé avec vous est ce que ce
que beaucoup d'efforts sont déployés
dans l'idée d'avec chef présente au
débat avec une petite besace le de l'ain
qui tua sortir au bon moment c'est utile
vous y croyez pas chez nous puis je vais
m'inscrire en faux avec mes deux
précédents collègues nous ont fait pas
de simulation avec avec les autres chefs
et monsieur asselin disait puis a tout à
fait raison c'est les quatre chefs
ensemble ce sont des sacrés quelque
chose de nouveau à chaque fois monsieur
duceppe ce sera la dixième et la onzième
fois qui débat avec avec monsieur on
peut donc le connais bien le poids des
battues en quarts ni avec monsieur
merkel ni avec monsieur trudeau alors ce
serait quelque chose qui va être
complètement différent mais n'ont pas de
pas de rien de préparé à l'avancé de
script à l'avancé
vous savez dans l'ensemble des
conseillers qui sont autour de monsieur
duceppe le meilleur pour sortir des
matches comme ceux là c'est monsieur
doucet et lui ce qu'ils veulent ce qui
va préparer en fait c'est
essentiellement le contenu les
différents angles du débat mais non on
ne prépare pas de ligne et en demo immo
en cinq mois pour passer un message sur
un chef sur un autre
catherine les
linky tuque et entendu votre chef dans
des débats je me doute de la réponse
mais j'aimerais vous entendre
écoutez je pense que la première chose
c'est passer les messages directement
aux électeurs
donc c'est sur ça que le chef que
stephen harper va s'attarder pendant
pendant les débats maintenant les lignes
qui tu viens c'est sûr qu'ils aient des
angles d'attaqué évident avec avec les
partis avec lesquels on est en
compétition donc on discute de sorts
discutent des arguments qu'on peut
mettre de l'avant la personnalité des
chefs est ce qu'on est ce qu un moment
donné on va chercher un peu à
déstabiliser l'adversaire ou à avoir
comme je disais tantôt une pointe
d'humour mais mais il ya aussi est-ce
qu'on va se retrouver sur la défensive
un moment donné où est ce qu'on va
capable de faire une percée dans le
débat ça c'est extrêmement important on
a vu le dernier débat était à peu près à
peu près nulles si on peut dire donc un
débat où il ya un gagnant et un perdant
ça peut changer beaucoup de choses dans
la campagne
maintenant je sais que nous les
journalistes et analystes politiques la
première chose qu'on nous demande tout
le temps c'est qui au grenier qui a
perdu vous vous êtes en studio vous êtes
à côté de vos chefs vous les regardez
savez-vous qui ils ont s'ils ont perdu
ou gagné
je voudrais qu'on roule un moment du
débat des chefs de 2011 qui avaient
beaucoup à l'époque marqué les esprits
qui ont été identifiées peut-être comme
un point tournant dans la campagne à ce
moment-là son échange d'aller voir dans
le débat en anglais
monsieur lettonie monsieur ignatieff à
l'époque
donc quand on se présente pas au bureau
on demande pas une promotion sa crise
qualifiée comme une ligne qui dessus car
je commencerai avec vous à ce moment là
quand le débat était finie vous aviez
l'impression que c'était passé quelque
chose c'est quand même sur un enjeu
aussi obtus le sait la démocratie est
une erreur mais c'est surtout dans la
réaction de l'adversaire qu'on peut voir
qui s'est passé quelque chose
il semble que monsieur natif des pas
prêt à céder dakhla et n'a pas su réagir
qu'on compte de façon convaincante avant
les électeurs alors on pensait qu'on
avait réussi un bon coup cependant
l'impact s'est ressenti que plusieurs
jours plus tard au moment même où à
chaud c'est difficile de bien l'analyser
on applaudit les attaques de nos chefs
ont applaudi les bonnes lignes on
applaudit les bombes les bons points
mais il faut prendre un peu de recul ça
prend quelques jours pouvoir
on a vraiment marqué un gros point sur
cet échange là
robert vous étiez 2 de l'autre côté de
cette équation là vous avez senti le
coup porté à ce moment là où vous aussi
c'est après un peu de temps avant qu'on
condé quand non nettement sur coup on le
voit passer dans la réaction suivante
suivant des peuples les gens en parlent
mais je pense que l'extrait que vous
montrez montrait bien la dichotomie par
rapport à ce que les médias voient comme
étant l'analyse d'un débat et monsieur
lentement créatures à leur salon pour
moi l'objectif principal d'un débat
c'est très simple c'est communiquer aux
gens aux canadiens qu'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire
si on est élu
au gouvernement premier ministre
d'expliquer notre programme les médias
eux le voit beaucoup compte l'aspect
adverse et réal du débat la façon que
les gens se sont positionnés mais je
pense que ces deux façons vraiment
différente
la recherche démontre bien que quand les
gens regardent un débat les gens qui
suivent pas la politique comme nous a
tous les jours ce qu'ils veulent voir
c'est est ce que la personne à la
conférence que son programme est claire
ce qui est réussi à communiquer de façon
efficace
est ce que je comprends autrement dit à
la fin du débat
qu'est ce que la confiance de faire
s'ils gagnent le gouvernement je pense
que c'est là la grande différence car il
reste quelques secondes je vois que vous
voulez intervenir mais ils vont être
raison mais il ya 2 août histoire pour
un débat et les gens qui regardent le
débat et on fonctionne de cette façon là
mais les gens qui ne regardent pas
qu'ils vont se faire une idée du débat
avec les nouvelles télévisées et à ce
moment là les lignes comme cela devienne
très très importante
catherine il reste quelques catherine
dominique je vous donne 10 secondes
chacun vous vous devez préparer vos
chefs pour deux des bols public et le
débat sur le débat l'analyse qui en sera
fait après c'est sa 4e absolument c'est
pour ça que les pèlerins comme on dit en
anglais existe et on fait l'examen après
des médias ou dans quelle direction
savoir comment on peut l'influencer
effectivement il ya les gens chez eux où
on parle des choses qui l'aura qui leur
importe leur retraite l'argent dans
leurs poches puis l analyse médiatique
de comment le débat était le munich en
quelques secondes
effectivement influence communication au
produit quelque chose cette semaine qui
disait que dans le nom de nouvelles qui
a été générée par la campagne avait 6 %
qui était par les politiciens eux-mêmes
et 94 % qui était le commentaire alors
c'est extrêmement important non
seulement de passe à travers le débat
puisse assurer que le chef louis parler
des enjeux qu'on l'avait estime
important mais il faut aussi gagner le
débat sur le débat
gagner là près des bas alors vous vous
êtes tous en préparation pour la joute
de
10 je vous remercie d'avoir été avec
nous vos mérites merci au revoir